Brody what's your question for George
real quick Giorgio is announcer
Tarantino is doing a new Star Trek I
don't that's what I hear I got to tell
you something that sounds pretty cool
Quentin Tarantino's it was right doesn't
it sound exciting it does mean it brings
a whole new energy to it and people keep
asking me am I gonna be in it it's up to
them the guys riding it is the guy who
wrote the revenant you know that movie
with the bear yeah climbing into the
bear yeah that could be cool
that can be an alien monster yes so yeah
and all they have to do is ask me I'd be
more than happy to really return to Star
Trek be George Takei who wants to be in
it he does well you could have both well
he's eight years old
if 88 he's 88 oh he is a force of nature
I mean he's amazing
and he's still alive you mean yes he's
still showing up at Star Trek and busy
really yes
you've seen them I've seen him do you
talk to him we say good morning right
and it's just a cordial hello and that's
it that's it you know calm because it's
a house brand is luggage there you're
shuttling us you know from place to
place and that back in the corridor and
if we pass each other and we say good
morning we're civil because uh Shatner
still call you Georgie in that kind of
way
[Laughter]